our commencement speaker is an
interesting man
a famous man i have a private theory
about him that i'm going to explain
and it's an explanation why so many
people love him
and the kind of people who love him
he's the famous actor he was in the
santa claus trilogy
[Music]
he's he's buzzed lightyear
[Applause]
a bunch of us are old men motorcycle
riders and so we really like the movie
wild dogs
[Music]
and then home improvement and last man
standing
uh
when was the last show was it shown this
next tuesday
thursday next thursday is the last show
of last man standing you should all
watch it
now i haven't mentioned what is
far and away his greatest movie and one
of the greatest movies
ever made it's called galaxy quest
i can tell you that my son-in-law was
not permitted to marry my daughter until
he had seen that movie
and said that he liked it
i mean what if his taste was so far off
he didn't like it
and and you know it's wonderful
but why is it wonderful
well i think his body of work
has a theme in it and it's the reason i
love it
captain taggart
he's a showboat and he drinks too much
and he goes around bemoaning his faded
glory and showing off on the stage to
weird teenagers and uh
but then some things happen and he
actually gets himself in a war
a big war a dangerous war
and it emerges in this war
that he was never a fraud when he says
never give up never surrender
at going winston churchill it emerges
that he meant that and that's why the
movie is good
that's why he becomes a better man when
he gets to actually do that
he's not just interested in sigourney
weaver for her body anymore
although i fancy that didn't go away
and he recognizes his peers in a greater
act of justice than he used to do when
he just hogged the limelight
don't you see it's what all of us want
we want to be good and fine if we can we
want to be noble
and brave and that's why in last man
standing in home improvement
the guy's kind of a foolish guy in both
cases but also
there's something reliable about that
guy
and he's there when he's needed for the
people who depend on him
and he depends on them in other words
he demonstrates the hero in all of us
and makes us better thereby tim allen
thank you
how in the hell am i supposed to follow
that
good god anyway um jesus
jenny who was he talking about
i'm sitting there anyway i i am welcome
to this room and i'm so amazed to be
here
thank you dr arn and all of the faculty
and the family and the friends and the
donors and everybody for having me here
and of course the
families and the special guests pat
sajak of course right here
all of whom must be saying who is this
again
why is he standing there i seriously
i considered this thing so many i said
yes to this i don't really believe i
actually actually said yes to it
there's a lot of calls let me think i
got stuff to do
i got to ride my bike i don't
it brought up so many things that i have
to think about but i was terrified of it
i really was
it's a great honor actually to digest
this being here
humbled is the word i've seen almost two
days of this and all of you people
and orchestras and the students and
actually
changed me i came in with some ideas and
i now have to really
flourish my ideas in my head to say what
i'm going to say
this isn't las vegas as some of my
writers said please don't do your vegas
act
in front of these people i
so much want to i mean there's some of
me that
we got the whitmer jokes out he could
say it why can't i do this
breathe
no no no look hey
i get it i forget that i'm in michigan
again and of course
pure michigan for the last 11 years i've
been the voice of this great state
for their tourism thank you i have to
only share it when i'm in michigan i
know a lot of people here
aren't actually from michigan but when
i'm doing those voice commercials
it's also steps out of my comfort zone
taking orders from people in studios and
mccann erickson downstate
i think i'm a big shot i know how to
talk no you don't
slow it down and i learned how to do
great voice-overs for an absolutely
gorgeous
magnificent state which i adore but
every now and then you'd be in a studio
and they'd go
it's after this grand haven in the
beaches and the beautiful michigan
sunsets fishing
walking with your family cut two when
you tour the great bean fields of the
saginaw valley
and i'd have to go can we stop for just
a second
has anybody been to the goddamn
greenfields of saginaw valley
no offense to people who live in the
bean fields of saginaw valley but
god i don't want to visit the bean
fields of saginaw valley
you go to bay city there's a riverwalk
but let's move
quickly pass it to kwaminan bridge and
get up north
yeah i honor this end of the chapter in
your graduate's life
the class of 2021 hillsdale applaud you
guys
it is an amazing day and now it starts a
new chapter and that's
kind of where it came from to me what my
college thinking
you think of me as mike baxter as you
heard tim the toolman
taylor buzz lightyear all of these
characters
were never my goal that's that's where i
go off track here
i'm all of those things and literally
none of those things
to be honest with you i i'm a family
comedian on television i do
disney movies santa claus for god's
sakes and
the truth is i hate children
sorry one of mine is right there in
front of me and she hears this
i'm fond of you
i did the santa claus movie and it was
one of my prayers
in a bad part of my life i asked god i i
want to be
on the johnny carson show and that's i
prayed and i prayed and i prayed
in a desperate time of my life to focus
on that i got on the tonight show but
never as
a comedian which is what i've been for
44 years i was on there for home
improvement in santa claus
and i was telling god damn it i hate
children how did you do this to me
i did a santa claus movie in santa claus
outfit
with children as extras we didn't use
short people or what the game of thrones
dude size whatever the legal term is for
that
we didn't you i don't know what you're
supposed to say anymore you can't say
any word
i live in the people's republic of
california so we get reminded all the
time which you can and cannot think or
say
but i do a movie dressed as santa claus
and children
are like cats the more you dislike them
the more they come around you
i walked into the dressing room with the
director i said you've got to keep these
damn kids away from me
they're bugging me asking me about this
ask about this he said you got to slow
down and stop using the f-bomb in front
of these kids all right
you're dressed like santa claus i said
oh hell i am i looked in the mirror i
said well i get it
and i had kids asking me because they're
wonderful
but kind of stupid come on kids you know
they're what does santa claus
eat how the hell would i know what santa
claus eats
i come up a reindeer i guess i mean
they're
how it's all i could come up with
a lot it was a lot of pressure to do
this gig so i went online and i looked
up a lot of other commencement speeches
how they do them
and generally the good ones had had
somehow had a music track behind them
and i i thought i couldn't really afford
anything i have a buddy has a
polka band at kalkaska that doesn't seem
right it just
seemed a bit germany umpi thing so
it would help me if you visualize oboz
based bassoons behind me right now it'll
it'll help with everything just in your
head consider a big band back here
because maybe it'll work maybe it won't
about me i started my love of philosophy
that's what i went to school for
religious studies philosophy design
that's where i started so i say that
with part of my history is the
foundation of my present moment
i sit here and i accept as everyone
must i think the blessings in their life
but if that is true the blessings make
my life so are the tragedies
of my life and the mistakes they define
me as well as my blessings
self-will or determination that's been
my life all through my life the
arguments i've had with god is it your
will
or is it my will or is it determined if
you're a philosophy major
you get into this a priori and
determination if you're a physics guy
with the slit experiment hey it might be
both so
study physics and you'll go freaking
nuts that's what'll happen
tragedy defines something in my life age
11 my father was killed tragically
and we lived in denver colorado and my
world turned upside down
i was a popular kid in denver schools
and i moved with my
mom's family back to detroit outside of
detroit during the riots
at that time it was 68 didn't know there
was tanks that was kind of
interesting to me i said i think i'm
going to like this place i'd had no idea
what that was about riots but look
there's an army tank i love tanks
this is going to be a nice place to live
as a popular kid in denver
i moved to detroit outside of detroit
where people did not wear white socks
with converse
you were mentally challenged if you wore
that
my family name is dick i had adolescent
acne i was a new kid in the school
from popular to geeky i knew
immediately about
horror cruelty judgment it was
in my face all the time i reacted with
anarchy like i normally do
i withdrew i learned how to lie
effectively
i mean that's literally what i do for a
living
i say [ __ ] that doesn't mean anything to
me but i i hope i say it well enough
that you say hey that's a great thing i
get
dishonesty but i also utilize my gifts
of comedy to
separate myself from other people it's a
good defense mechanism i became
exactly like che guevara once knew you
became what you resent
every revolutionary will come up to this
point where they become exactly what
they hated
just look at cuba i everything i envied
i was jealous of i became that i did
what i did to become a very popular kid
in the
school down state i moved up into the
popular good but you know what's funny
about me when i thought about
i always remember the kids that were
there with me when i was geek
the av guys the auto shop when they had
shop remember that
at ethics class remember that ethics
what are those things that's
that's the hat off thing but all the
kids that were there with me when i was
a geek
never forgot them as it turns out every
every class reunion you go back to my
school and all the geeks run companies
all the cool kids are living outside of
barns
i'm gonna get a job one of these days
yep
i'm on disability from gm i thought you
fixed your knee yeah well now it's my
other side i work that other side and i
got a disability thing
i was never a very good student school
got in the way of
goofing around i was sent to the
principal's office i can't tell you how
many times for being a disruption in
class now i didn't look at it that way
i was funnier than the teacher
you want to think he hit me with a ruler
once and slipped me
from here to here he apologized i said
it's not your problem i went down
a very big problem when a teacher draws
blood i don't care what area you're in
it's not good
i come home every parent that i stopped
oh my god what happened i get home
my mother looks at me and she goes what
did you do
the great mom raised there is nine of us
raised us well
kind of just was fatigued at one point
she her lie her line to me always was
tim
you aim too high
remember the glass is half empty tim
think about a civil service job you know
work for the government oh god no
all my favorite teachers all my life
were the ones i hated at the time
the ones that actually taught me
something miss arner
english teacher at my high school hated
that woman
but she demanded that i explain what
anarchy meant to me she didn't care that
i was anarchist she didn't care that i
didn't believe in american government
she just said
well explain your position that's
interesting
i liked that i didn't like teachers and
professors that taught me what to do but
i
what to think i don't want to give his
name away he was my
painting teacher in college
he didn't like what i was painting i
hated him
i said you're supposed to teach me how
to paint not what to paint
there's a there's a big difference he
didn't see the difference and by the way
your paintings suck horrible big
elephants and stupid stuff that he
painted i never learned how to paint
from him
college that was a big deal here i am i
regret
not going to hillsdale this is amazing
to be sitting here
history you teach constitution highest
standards of
education faculty is great students look
at all this stuff
promotes critical thinking and debate
imagine that
college doesn't take any money from the
government yes
yes come on
[Applause]
i would rank this school top of the heap
what i didn't want to go here i i lied
it was a that was a talking point
there's just way too much emphasis here
on grades
you know personality
not so much you know in a no slam to
where i went i went to central
michigan's university
in mount pleasant beautiful weather
there it's great it's i think it was a
minus 11 degrees every day in the middle
of the summer i've never
they had a film department where i met
one of my best
best professors ever what seven samurai
which is a great movie by kurosawa you
watch it seven samurai
it was bleeding into dinner time at
wheeler hall a lot of the students are
restless
they're getting to the end of the movie
that's the best part of that movie
subtitles black and white
japanese characters still it's an
amazing movie the baseline of so many
scripts you've seen today
there was eight of us were mesmerized
all these students okay we're gonna miss
the buffet
rushing back to wheeler hall to get
college food
the instructor paused put on the lights
he said please leave
and the eight of you that stick around
talk to me later he said put a seven on
your
final report your exams and you all get
a a in this class
because you you you felt the passion you
stuck around you gave up
dorm food whatever the hell that was i
went to western michigan university
after that followed they
built the first color tv studio
and it was amazing in all the brochures
of course the students were allowed to
use it but they did have the first color
tv studio we
had the black and white tube studio in
the basement which
was weird there the professor was
lynnwood bartley there was an english
professor who i hated also because it
was an eight o'clock class i was a
big partier which is one reason why i
went to western because it was listed
and played by magazines the top three
party schools in the country
where my focus was
when we walked into that class this
would be the fourth year or 30-year
college
and he was drilling people how stupid
they were he said let me read you
a term paper from a college student and
he went on to this thing bearded
scottish guy was amazing just dog eat
how stupid
we're high school juniors write better
than this and he taught
taught showed preposition and phrasing
and i still picked up very little
because most of the time we just want to
get out of there
there we have my first view of
rudderless
i love sailing i love being in boats but
the greatest boat
of all time has no direction without a
rudder it's a very simple little thing
the only thing you control in a sailboat
is the attitude of the sails the
attitude you don't control the wind the
water
the sailboat really you have the rudder
and the attitude and that comes back to
me
i had no direction at this point and
never i had point it was pointing to
certain things
not knowing what's going on next and i
applaud all of you
if there's one thing i would say that i
wish i did differently was get a
direction
as uncomfortable and as scary as that
seemed to me
16 years you learn from the party bosses
yep we're all communists when we're born
because you do what the party says
upstairs you wear what they tell you
what to wear you eat what they wear
you are a communist little child as you
grow up through
high school it's kind of so democratic
socialism but you're still
doing what somebody's telling you to do
you learn
it's one thing at a time when you're kid
simple monkey bars what do you do next
oh i'm gonna get that next little handle
right there
that's the next one very simple then
it's people telling you get dressed
you're going to be late stop lighting
your brothers on fire it's one
one thing that's the funniest thing
about men
you've got to keep men busy
give us any time as kids any time as
kids you were going to heal
hear three words hey will it burn
12 years of that you get some education
i moved on to college
that's that's where i started making
some of my own decisions on a practical
level
laundry how to cook stuff get to class
learn some responsibility
that's where i developed a really good
relationship what i call the ego
the ego definitely is not my amigo
ego is always there until there's pain
trouble
or law enforcement then the ego gets
gets out of your system and
it hides someplace leaving the meek
soulful guy
i'm not quite sure what just happened
options could be a bit uncomfortable
they certainly were for me
i found that the smallest decisions that
i made made the greatest impact later on
it's amazing again a rudder little small
declaration that rudder can send you out
of a very different direction
thornton wilder said i got a quote the
more decisions you are forced to make
alone the more you're aware of your
freedom to actually choose freedom to
choose is something to celebrate
do it here you taught about it however
it gets complex because there's good
choices
and then choices that are all the
opposite of that are bad choices at a
certain point in my life
i'm just not going to decide which in
fact philosophically a paradox no choice
is actually a choice
didn't seem to me at the time excuse me
so there i am graduating from college
no clue what i was going to do because i
never thought about it i was too busy
partying and not listening
so i decided to go into sales
wasn't what i studied but you could make
a lot of money in sales
unless it's the wrong kind of thing
you're selling
so there i am at a federal penitentiary
going now what mistake did i make here
i learned a lot in prison i really did
you right out of a good family structure
i i will give you humanity's lesson
prison isn't everything that you
fear it is it isn't everything that you
think it is at one point there's a
holding cell
where 16 of us are put into a room wait
waiting after sentencing where they're
going to send you off into whatever
chain mail they put you in
and there is a commode in the middle of
the room
and i'm thinking to myself i'm going to
die i'm like i can't do this i can't do
my thing in the i can't do it
i'm you know there's no way i waited
till late at night and i think i was
thinking my head i think
does the human body eventually just
explode i don't even know what happens
if you just don't use the commode
i gave up i gave up i got up sat down
people coming out of their cots they
said oh god here it comes some sort of
whipping or some sort of
they stood in a horseshoe around me
staring at me and as i proceeded they
all turned
around and formed a privacy
hood around me there's humanity where
you
least expect it people but i also
learned one thing i've told every group
that's asked me what'd you learn in
prison i said the biggest lesson about
prisons
is don't ever sell drugs to cops
that's it
it's not fair i lose it now because now
it's legal
and now california sends corners they
sell it because it's good for you
it's legal and i remember obama used to
say it's not fair i'd usually say what
what the hell does that mean just take
that word apart
fair what what the hell does it mean i i
tweeted it what
excuse me got real trouble because it
got you know twitter you never know what
you're going to say to piss them off and
they get
some guy from iowa says fair is where
you a pig goes to win a ribbon
people often shocked as we have some
good neighbors that didn't know that i'd
done any time said
that's amazing you're not you're not the
type of guy that would end up in prison
let me tell you
everyone can be that type of guy it's
about
missing opportunities being rudderless
it's about choices
until he says god you're right here guys
i was missing mentorship
decision making any kind of moral
compass even though i went to church all
my life although
never quite understood it because i was
an anglican episcopalians when the
bishop came i was an altar boy he had
that garbage can on his head or whatever
that weird basket is
and i was whispering what part of the
bible is that mentioned that
that thing the conal thing
no answer from the bishop
he wasn't allowed to talk to me you got
to be in that little kneel on some
little weird thing and you can't move
and i was wobbling the whole time didn't
have enough
liquid i was anyway moments of clarity
have helped me all my life and that is
the grace of god to me
and even though i did never met it and
after the death of my father i hated god
of my misunderstanding
but every now and then right before i
was sentenced
to my well-deserved crime i
had a moment of clarity go on stage and
downstate in detroit i
set up for the comedy castle wrote 20
minutes of material went and practiced
and practiced
left them laughing did all the things
required of me and focused and engaged
focused and engaged the owner said you
got what it takes i think
we put you on the saturday schedule it's
going to be great every saturday and i
go
look at me a little problem i think i
got to do 38 months before that saturday
to this day that guy always mentioned
how dry i was oh
great great saturday well that'll be in
a 38 months with edward that's
kind of a saturday and he goes it
happened though it gave me something to
look forward to
um victor frankel's great book man's
search for meaning
in no way do i assume any of that but he
pointed his
energy to engagement on something past
the horror that he was going through
amazing book amazing book aim where you
want to go
not where you don't want to be that's
what i learned in racing i used to race
for ford motor company went through race
school and if you stare at the wall long
enough that you don't want to hit
guess what you're going to go hit that
wall do not aim where you don't want to
be
keep that off of your radar aim where
you want to go
that's what it was learn what your
passion was make better choices i
thought when i was incarcerated
passion you look it up if you look it up
webster's if you can
believe them webster says whoever
webster is
webster says passion intense sexual
desire whoops
all right all right that's a bit awkward
let's go to number two they have another
one under here
a love or desire or devotion some
activity object or concept an emotion
that is deeply stirring
ungovernable right another moment of
clarity for me
i started reading biographies of people
unlike me
what they did and believe it or not i
don't care whether a different gender
different
tribe they did things that i could do
that
it was it was formidable to me another
moment of clarity is
accomplishments are relative
in prison if you do what you're told and
i did what i was told finally
i needed that guidance i did exactly
what i was told mentored other people
in the religious studies i did a
toastmasters
and eventually you get out of group
cells you get out of the dorms you get
eventually
moved into the you move up the food
chain
i was so proud of my movement i called
my mother on a collect call which it
always have to be
from the prison thanksgiving i could
tell my family in the kitchen
chattering and she goes hold on tim's on
the phone what's up tim
guess what mom i got my own cell
hold on a minute tim's got his own cell
everybody
that's good dave just got into u of m
bruce just graduated she's at purdue but
tim's got his own sale
thank god i've got something to tell the
bridge club don't call here again
how do you know what your passion is for
me i knew what it wasn't
i was lucky enough to get a job as tool
and die because i love cars i love
building cars i got a tool and die
shop job over a summer between my
semesters at western and i made locating
pins on a sheldon turret lathe
i realized i never could do that without
killing myself
you made 80 locating pins a day that's
what you do it's 126 different movements
that's it that's it i so applaud
anybody that has the peace of mind to do
that i'm too add i could not do that
knowing what you don't want focuses on
what i did want
lily tomlin did a one-woman show which
was terrific by the way
played a homeless person she said it
it's i should have set my goals more
specifically what i wanted to do instead
of a homeless girl set goals it was
really weird
she said it make people laugh to me all
my life
has been more rewarding than anything
and i never thought of that as passion
that's what it was i would don't say my
don't don't repeat this i would probably
do my concerts for free
now the ego goes [ __ ]
that's the only use for the ego really
is deal with the irs that's who
that's that's what you need
i just have to this just was this week
the irs
had a refund checked coming to my office
for a considerable amount of money they
had trouble finding me
it's two years they couldn't find me but
they could find me immediately to tell
me that they couldn't find me
and when you're audited do they have any
trouble finding you
no can't even say what's on my mind
about the irs
goal setting there's a difference juan
montoya the race driver said focus is
different than goals
wishing is different than focus rather
wishing i was successful is one thing
focusing on successes and they sound the
same they're not the same aim where you
want to go not where you don't want to
be
you have to wishing to me it's like
sitting in the car and revving the
engine
well it seems like we're moving the
motor's running everything
i'm in the car you're just putting
stress on the engine
focus and goals put it in gear engage
and go
that means making move go engage they
seem very similar but they're not
i read about successful people in my job
it was more about people then i started
zeroing in on people that
you have to go 1961 to see lenny bruce's
speech
at the purple onion you can't even talk
about it on twitter now
go read what that guy said about
language and thought what that comedian
said
he went dark after that but his his
story is amazing richard pryor
what i saw in detroit once changed my
life that the way he could do that
that became what i wanted to do
what are the diversions i said
making goals is one thing but making a
list this is where i make the
the biggest impact of my life and it
sounds so simple i will challenge you
all to do this
three things you write down make a list
of what you're going to do the rest of
the day
make a list of what you're going to do
this year and the most difficult one and
don't tell anybody about yourself what
am i going to do
what am i going to do sounds simple the
one will tell you how to do number two
and two will tell you how to set up to
do number three
what do you want to do i didn't know
my goal list when i started it 20
minutes on the set that was hot as hell
i did not want to be a opening neck i
want to be a closing act i got that
number two i wanted to save a hundred
thousand dollars and literally had no
way to do that
i finally did that and i got a lot of
toasters
early on you kept moving your money to
different banks they give you toasters
or some weird kind of appliance and so i
had
i was living with my parents because i
was on parole my mom said what are all
these toasters doing in here
just wait a little appliance store i'll
figure out something to do with these
things
and the third was to get on the tonight
show somehow explain that i did it on
the tonight show but i was ungrateful
and pissed at god i didn't want to i
wanted to be
a comedian on the tonight show
then add value to everything i
set up to do this was something i
learned from the great bob seger
he said put butts in the seats add value
to the situation you're in i don't care
what situation i was in
i added value to it it was different
when i was gone
engage put butts in the seats in my
business
it was it learned how other people put
butts in the seats and
then the club owner the business if you
could sell you can do anything you want
to do
having no vision is no solution
everything depends on execution that's a
lyric of the song
i've got a great idea and that's where
it ends you watch the shark tank every
now and then you watch this motivation
of people to get stuff done
it's amazing to watch that thing also i
suggest getting fired
that was a great thing i got fired a lot
i kind of liked it i lived for it
thomas edison he said opportunity is
missed by most people because it's
dressed in overalls it looks like
work mark twain said the harder i try
the luckier i got
it takes hard words and patience i
didn't know that
i failed at that and that's why i ended
up where i was
big thing that stopped me was diversions
i called diversions
and the biggest one because i'm in a
a cult written by bill wilson
and it's false evidence appears real
which is fear fear stopped me from doing
everything
coherent in my life i was i was afraid
of shadows
great story i took my older daughter to
school once and a shadow came across the
windshield i shrieked
and i pulled into it almost hit a tree
and the fear of what was going to happen
was caused by a butterfly flying between
the sun and my car
and that shadow the fear of that was
huge the actual
i'm scared of butterflies now this is
this is awkward
people spend a lot of energy spinning
wheels irrationally on fear
again mark twain i've had a lot of
troubles in my life most of which never
happened
it will stop you and of course my
favorite ego boy
not my amigo i always think of ego as a
necessary i can't even remember the name
of the book when
as soon as we had a moment to think
about our activities
men will light a match women will think
it's doing something useful
men will just i wonder if it hurts to do
that
here try that stick it that hurts you
try no it really hurts it
this tastes terrible here try that
why would i eat that but i did my older
brother this this makes me throw up hear
you try it
makes me throw up too okay let's keep
eating that
[Music]
you can't have a human being that's
grateful
with his hands full of toys every little
baby i've ever had
has toys in their arms as soon as you
pull out another toy they go mine
mine mine as if god was saying you have
your hands full i can't give you
anything more unless you let some of
that go
okay you got to pass it along you got to
move along and babies
i don't think we ever really grow out of
that get out of your own way that was
that was my problem god's always there
in my life
but he's polite and doesn't like to
interrupt
constantly talking to myself and the ego
pretends to be good
in me anyway my best advice that i never
took again i love these
albert einstein said famously i hope
summoned
invents air conditioner no that wasn't
him
that was a joke somebody wrote for me i
i'm not taking credit for that because
it
just didn't land he actually said i'm
not a genius i'm passionately
curious curiosity man that was great of
course my mom said it killed the cat
well i'm not a goddamn cat what does
that have to do with me i don't
understand that
it's an asset it's an asset on every
level
question question question right now i
wish i'd questioned more
instead of running out of good
graduation just ran out
and did what i always do is divert
divert
curiosity is a tremendous asset if you
want to be the smartest person in the
room
question the smartest person in the room
learn to be a great listener god bless
learn to be a great listener
shut up and listen shut up and listen
you've been around great professors and
a great
actually a great speaker back here jesus
if you want to be interesting
you have to be interested ultimately
these are the questions i had to ask
myself and i wished i'd asked him
literally wish somebody had asked him
before the penitentiary
although saturday breakfast wasn't bad
and you always knew what to wear i did
like that i hate clothes
i think i'm going with khaki today
maybe a white t-shirt
ultimately this is a new chapter
and i i can't tell you how you guys
affected me that those i've met in that
orchestra your faces your intelligence
your
uh i don't know it's amazing
so what kind of person do you want to be
you're already a
damn good start between your parents in
this place you guys are a damn good
start
it's not where i was i wish someone had
asked me that
are you going to be a person with
integrity are you going to take
responsibility for your actions
i made amends to my mother for all that
i did i paid her back for everything
doesn't seem to be enough can you be
flexible and let go of ridges
bad experiences are you open to other
points of view listen to the other point
of view before you jump in and tell me
yours
are you gonna complain about things are
you gonna figure out how to fix it
and how do you handle accomplishments
and i said i've been blessed with people
giving me credit up here and i never
even thought about it
when you achieve success will you be
possibly
the type of person that reaches out in
hands give freely what you get to others
is it it's very difficult to do it
because it's mine mind mine
you want to become the person you admire
because the only person i cannot get
away from
is me i mean i'm here every time i go i
go over there and i'm still standing
over there i said so no matter what
argument i'm having with myself
i'm right here again still here
humans are not plants i've heard
that we need each other
there's a a story that
changed another one of these watershed
moments in my life me and god have had
this
weird relationship and as a philosopher
and studied so much you end up asking
dark questions
and there's no answer to it as some
famous guy in one of my scripts said
we only it's only god's will when we
like it if we don't like it well
that's free will that's uh did satan
well didn't god invent satan
no he couldn't have been satan i don't
know didn't he harden the pharaoh's
heart
couldn't even just let him go i had
these questions as a kid
so i've always had these problems with
the god of my misunderstanding
i had a terrible racing car accident and
ripped open a
big fissure in my gut so they have to
close up the gut
but for a while period of time you have
to use a called a stoma to
remove waste products so there's a tube
sticking out of my side and there's a
tube
sticking out in my throat i'd had some
family problems at the same time i was
losing weight it was not getting better
and i stayed in the hospital and a buddy
came by who has since passed dear friend
of mine but he came by with a movie and
another friend came by to talk
didn't want to see anybody but i did and
then they gave me food for the first
time
and the doctor came in not even moments
later it was about a half hour later he
saw the look on my face he goes
i knew what he knew this is it wasn't
working my digestive system wasn't
working
and i started weeping and he said this
is going to be very uncomfortable
because we can't go in through the
suture we have to find other ways to go
get that food
and we can't go down your throat it was
i don't want to be
horribly dramatic about that it just was
everything was bad news and he said and
it's going to get worse and worse until
we get it out
so i woke me up at three in the morning
to do the worst they could do i'm
standing there
you can't imagine the humility that i
felt that what what was on my body i'm
standing there looking out of a window
at los angeles saying please dear father
this is as bad this is low as i can get
it can't get any lower than this
it would be just could you tell me
something
and i don't the way i pled it
i please say something to me
and within moments a voice that was my
voice and i swear as i stand here was
not my voice said it's going to be okay
it's real it changed i
i still get pissed at him i still don't
stay grateful but
it is so true in my heart that this is a
real deal
we are in this thing together you're
going to
however you want to believe it i really
believe it's right here in all my
philosophy aside and all my physics
stuff
doesn't explain the connection that this
has and i said
i want to say through this class of 2021
go forth and conquer you come from a
very good place you've got the best
fertilizer the best
seed sows and all that listen to what
people tell you
learn from the teachers you have focus
because you've got a
world out there that's out of focus and
this the substitute teachers in the room
there are no adults
there are no adults in the room we need
you you got to save the world
no pressure no pressure
we're counting on you thank you all for
inviting me here
don't take life too seriously i had made
a living on that and one of my best
friends in the world
will say as i leave here you guys are
headed to infinity
and beyond
[Applause]
i have a lot of evidence that that was a
great speech by your reaction but a
particular one
proves it my wife has a way of looking
at me
sideways with amused disapproval
whenever i'm showing off
and she's had her look on it my ear look
that look on her face for the last 25
minutes
naughty boy kind of look
i want to introduce
tim allen's wife jane and his daughter
who has yesterday become a member of the
class
of 2033.
would you stand up please yeah
[Applause]
and don't don't worry about these people
immediately behind you the worst of them
will probably be dead by then
tim please come
and thanking you for being here and for
your career
which is a great thing and on behalf of
the faculty of hillsdale college and
with the authority invested in me by its
board of trustees
i hereby hereby confer upon you the
honorary degree
doctor of fine arts yeah
you